develop as a 2d cross platform free and open
source game engine. Wesley and Max teach this
course. They're both game developers
and teachers. And this course is the
best way to get started with G develop. Hey
there, my name is Wesley, and this is Max.
And we're going to take you from zero knowledge
to releasing a game with G develop. In this video,
I'm going to start us off with the general layout
of G develop. When you first download G develop,
you'll be met with this screen. From here you can
open an existing project or start a brand new one.
When you click on create a new project, you'll
be given a bunch of options for starter games
and examples. We're going to skip all those for
now and just go straight for a blank game. When
you start from scratch like this, you need to
add a new scene, which is where you'll actually
make the game. To keep things organized, it's
important to make sure that you give your scenes
appropriate titles. Since we opened a blank game
project, we need to open some of the panels. Up
here in the top right corner, you'll see some of
the options. You'll also have the ability to add
a grid to your game project to help organize
things. And to change the level of zoom. Let's
start with the object panel. This is where you're
going to import and manage your game objects.
Everything from your characters to your
tiles to your particle effects will all
show up in this panel. We'll start by creating
a sprite the most commonly used game object,
you should make sure to give this a title that
makes sense. Click add an animation, find the
art that you want to use, and open it, be sure
to click Apply to save any work that you've done.
And then you can just drag the object
straight from the panel into the game space.
You can drag to click on multiple objects
at a time and use the middle mouse button to
move the scene around and zoom in and out.
The next panel over is for object groups.
It's a useful tool that lets you target a group of
objects as opposed to each individual one when you
want to do things with them. For example, I could
have a bunch of parts and potions and food items
and call all of them healing items. And then I
can make a single event that makes it so that
if the player is in collision with one
of those healing items, they get healed,
instead of making a different event
for every single item in the list.
Next up is the Properties panel. When this
panel is open, and you click on an object,
you'll get to see their position, Z order angle,
and so on. And from this panel, you can actually
control all of those things, moving them around
changing their angle and changing the Z order,
which is what decides whether an object
is behind or in front of another one.
And that's a good transition to talking about
layers. With the Layers panel you can create
different layers to place objects on. So you can
create a foreground mid ground and background
as well as UI layers and menu layers.
Typically, you'll put most for game
objects on the base layer, and have that
camera following the player while having
all of your UI objects and menus on different
layers where the camera is stationary. From this
panel, you can also add effects to layers, edit
their properties, and toggle their visibility.
Back to the Properties panel. You can
also use this panel to resize objects.
But be careful while doing this because changing
an images resolution can really make it blurry.
The last panel is for the instance list. This
can be a useful tool for finding where things
are in your game project, especially once they've
gotten so big that you can't tell where things
are anymore. You'll notice these window tabs up
top, the start page and then your main scene page
where all of the game building is done.
And then that scenes event list where
all of the black magic happens. But we'll get
to that in another video. Up in the top left,
you can open your project manager. And in
the game settings, you'll find properties.
This is where you'll do things like change
the game's name, give it a version number,
a package name an author, login with your
profile, and change the games resolution, which
is something you should definitely do because
very few devices are defaulted to 800 by 600. You
can also tell the engine here how to expand the
game to meet the size of the screen that it's in,
as well as tweaking the max and min
frame rates that the game will run at.
for mobile devices. You can choose whether the
game runs in portrait mode or landscape mode,
and then you can turn on and off anti aliasing.
The only real reason you would turn this feature
off is if your game uses pixelart. And if your
game is running ads, then this is where you
would slot in your app ID. You can also edit
the game's initial loading screen from here.
The rest of the project Game Settings has global
variables, which we'll get to at another time
icons, which are your desktop and mobile app icons
and resources. Which is where you can go and see
all the assets that are in your game file. There
are a few options here that you might need, like
when individual objects are blurry or if an object
or sound effect is stuttering before it loads in.
The rest of the Project tab has the scenes that
we've already talked about external events and
layouts, which we plan to explain in another
video. And then functions and behaviors. And
if you wanted to use the prebuilt extensions that
include things like giving the enemy's health and
different movement systems, then this would
be the place to get those. And we're going to
tackle that in another video as well. Let's close
this project and open one of the starter games.
You'll see that all of the games objects
have loaded into the objects panel,
as well as the events and the game
itself. Now in the top left corner,
the two last things to talk about are the Export
button, which is what you would use when you're
finished building your game and you want to
release it to the public. And the Preview button,
which is what you would use to play test your
own game. When you click this button, it will
play from whichever scene you're on currently,
it'll open up a window, and I can just play
one last thing that before you go. This is
something that I didn't know about. Even
though I've used the engine for over two years.
And to see all these panels, they can all move.
Now this isn't revolutionary. But this
does allow you to customize your workspace
and set it up so that it works best for you.
Though this is probably not how the developers
top people would use it. Next, I'm going
to go over the object types in G develop.
We start off with the basic scene. And on
the right hand side you'll see the objects
that have imported into the game. We're going to
click on add a new object. And from here you're
going to see all the options. We're going
to begin though with the most commonly used
object which is a sprite, which we already
have labeled in the scene as the player.
Sprites are able to have different animations
where you add in each frame of the animation.
Pick the speed that the animation plays at and
decide whether or not it should loop. You can also
label animations to make them easier to use later.
To add more animations to a sprite, just click
add an animation. Down here in the bottom left
corner, you can edit the sprites collision mask,
you can also edit points that are on the
sprite on the bottom left hand side as well.
Every object can be given behaviors and effects.
Behaviors are prebuilt game logic that you can
use to help make your game faster. So if we give
the player character the platform or behavior,
you can see there's a bunch of numbers in here
that you can tweak. But you can leave those as
default if you want to. And then if we give
the player character, the drop shadow effect,
we get a character that has a drop shadow, and
one that can move when you press the arrow keys.
A quick side note for the platformer behavior. If
you don't give the ground that they're standing on
the platform behavior, then your character
will just fall out of the screen.
Speaking of the ground, let's move on to the
next object, which is a tiled Sprite, we use
tiled sprites, because if you grab a regular
sprite and try to change the size, it will scale,
whereas tiled sprites will duplicate instead of
changing size. So you can use this for a bunch
of different things like level design and UI. The
next object type is text, you can change the size,
color and font of this object, and then write
in whatever you would like to to fill it in.
And then you can use the event system to change
what's written in this object during your game.
Next up is the particle emitter, you can use the
particle emitter for a whole range of things.
But the two most important parts are particle
kind, which come in point line and texture,
texture being one that you can import yourself
to create whatever kind of particle you want.
And the number of particles in tank.
If this is set to negative one,
the particle emitter will stay there forever
in your game. If it's set to a positive number,
then it will use that many particles and
then stop. You can either place them in scene
to start when the scene starts, or use the
event system to spawn them where we need them.
Next is the nine patch panel Sprite, you
import an image. And then it's easiest to
show you this from the wiki. You put the size of
your margins into the nine patch panel Sprite.
And then it will expand in the way that you see
on screen, maintaining the ratios of the outside
edges. And this can be used for dialog boxes,
UI design, and a bunch of different things.
The shape Painter is also easiest to
explain from the example in the wiki.
Basically, this can be used to create a range
of shapes for UI way points, selection tools,
and things like that. The text entry object is
used to enter text, you create the object, put
it in scene, and then using this simple event and
the Hello World text object that we made earlier,
the game will record and display what I'm typing
into my keyboard. Next is the BB text, which is
very similar to the basic text object. But you're
able to do more things with fonts and effects.
If you don't need to use these effects, you're
better off just using the basic text object.
The light object can be used to create some
dynamic shadows, I just create the object,
place it in scene, and then give the player
character the light obstacle behavior. And then
you can see that the light is being obstructed by
the players collision mask that we set up earlier.
The last object type video is pretty
straightforward. You just pick the videos,
opacity, volume, and then import the video, it's
best to use an mp4 For compatibility reasons.
And then you can control the stopping and
starting of the video through the event system.
Now that that's out of the way, we can
start talking about the event system
will begin with a scene that I've
set up and go into the event sheet.
From here, we can add an event. And
we'll zoom in to make it more readable.
So the easiest way to think of the no code
system is to think of if then, so if this side,
the condition side is true, then this
side, the action side will happen.
So I'm going to set up a simple event, I'm going
to search for key pressed, and then type in D.
And then for an action, I could search for
this again. But I can also click on an object,
and it will give me a list of things
that will only relate to that object,
I could search down this list to find the things
that I want. But because I know what I want,
I'm just going to type in force and select
Add a force is going to give it a positive
power in the x direction, and then zero in the y
direction. And I'm going to leave it at instant
because an instant force will only apply while
the condition is true, whereas a permanent force
will stay with that object permanently. And now
when I press preview, and hold down the D key,
the player object will very slowly move
to the right. Back in the event sheet,
I can add more events by clicking here, here,
or by right clicking and selecting new event.
Now I can drag this event over and turn it into
a sub event of our original event. I'll add the
action, rotate, select the player and give it
an angular speed. I'm also going to increase
the speed for the apply force event. And now when
I press D, the character rotates and moves faster.
What's happening is the main event is being
checked to see if its conditions are true.
And if those conditions are true, then it
will move down and check the sub events.
But if we drag this event over and turn it back
into a regular event, it has no conditions. So
when we preview the game, now, the character
will be rotating constantly. But still, when I
press the D key, it will move over. I can copy and
paste existing events rather than just constantly
creating new ones. And then I can modify this to
make an effect a different object. Realizing that
this might be a little hard to see, I'm going to
create one final event, I could click on other
conditions and manually search for the condition
that I need. But since I know what I want already,
I'm just going to search for at the beginning of
scene, which is a condition that only triggers
once at the beginning of the scene. And
then I'll add zoom camera and type into.
You can delete individual actions and conditions
by selecting them and pressing Delete as well
as entire events. And then you can press Ctrl Z
or ctrl y to undo or redo anything you've done.
You can right click an event
and move it into a group
groups are useful to help organize your
project. Giving these appropriate names
is incredibly important. There are a few other
things that you can add to your event sheet
like comments, which will help you label your
game events to remind you of what each one does.
A couple of the more useful event types
that you can add are for each object,
which is an event that will repeat every frame
for every object of that type in the game.
So if I have 20 player objects in the game,
then it will repeat for all 20 player objects.
Another commonly used event type is
repeat, which, as the name implies,
is one that you can set up to repeat X number
of times per frame. And speaking of per frame,
the engine reads the event list once per
frame. If you go to the project manager,
you can see that the game is defaulted to force
the game to run between 20 frames per second and
60 frames per second. You can edit those if you
need to. But I would generally leave this alone.
Let's quickly talk about organization.
And I'll show you why it's important after
if we open up one of the starter games that you
can use. You can see how nicely set up everything
is with comments and sub events set up to make
sure that it's easy You'd understand at a glance,
rather than having to read every event to see what
each one does. But you can further organize your
game using groups to group everything together,
you can then pick a color for the group header,
and comments. To show you why organization
is so important, I'll open up the events
for a game jam game that I made. If you don't
organize your events from the beginning,
you'll find it getting out of hand really
quickly, till you get to the point where
it's almost impossible to fix anything in your
game. Because you don't know where the event is,
you can use the search bar to try to find
it. But sometimes that's just not enough.
And now that we have an event complicated
enough to show you how this works, I'm going
to really quickly go over how the engine checks
events. So every frame the event list is checked.
But it checks the event list from top to bottom,
checking each condition from top to bottom.
And then if that condition is true,
then all of these actions will happen
from top to bottom. Now that you know the
basics of the event system, I can go over all
the tools that G develop has integrated into the
engine to help you jump right into making games.
When you open G develop, you'll be given the
option to create a new project or open an existing
one. If you click on Create new project, you'll
see a list of starter games and examples that
you can learn from and build off of, which
are all under the MIT license. Which means
that you're free to use anything here for your
projects that are just for fun, or commercially.
If we go back to these starter games, and click
on one, you can see that it's loaded in all of the
objects and events required for this game. If I
click on Preview, I can just play this game as is.
Most of these starter games are just the base
logic you need for that type of game. So they'll
usually only have one example level in them.
But you can build on those if you want to.
If we go back to the game that I was using in
the previous video, I can show you behaviors,
behaviors or pre built logic that will help you
make your games faster. You'll see that there's
a bunch of these that come with the engine. But
we also have community built behaviors created
by other game developers that you can find by
clicking here and searching those behaviors.
A quick side note here, these community built
behaviors are the same thing as community built
extensions, the only difference being that
they're filtered to only show you the ones
that apply to the object. If you'd like to see the
full list of extensions, you can find that here.
If we go back to the default behaviors, we
can click on top down movement and turn off
rotation. And then we have a character that'll
move around on screen when I press the arrow keys.
So now if I go back in, I can add another
behavior. And I'm going to pick draggable object.
So now I've got a character that can move around
with the arrow keys. And I can drag it around with
the mouse. But now that I'm done with those, I
can delete them. And now we'll talk about Pisco,
the engines built in image editor. I've mostly
used this to correct the orientation of an image
by flipping it or rotating it. But you can use
this to make brand new images or to edit existing
ones. Next up is the sound creation tool. J
FXR. If you put in the action play a sound,
you'll see a prompt that will let you open up J
FX are a tool that can be used to create a range
of different sounds by manually correcting
sliders, or by randomizing them like this.
Next up is the engines Asset Library. If you click
on add a new object, you can click here to create
one from scratch. Or you can search the asset
library, which is currently a manually curated
collection of art assets that you can freely
use in your games. When you click on an asset
that you like, you'll be able to see which artists
created it and what license the assets are under,
you can click on the license to be brought to
a page that will explain the license to you.
The CC zero license for example, means
that you're allowed to use these assets
in your game, whether it be commercial or
not, without having to credit the artist.
Other assets in the library, though,
might be under a different license
that would require you to credit the artist.
If you like a particular piece of art,
you can click on the name of the artist and
it'll bring you to more works by the artist.
This for example is Kenny art, which is an
artist whose work I'm actually using right now.
So to continue using their art, I'm
going to grab this background tile,
click to add it to the game. And then I'm going
to create a background layer and put the image
on it. Making sure to put the background
layer below the base layer so it's behind it
And tada, my game now has a more interesting
background. So those are some of the tools
that G develop has brought together to
help you in jumpstarting the game making
process. You've got starter games and examples
built in and community built behaviors. Pistol
for image editing, J effects are to help you
with your sound effects, and the assets library.
So if I give the player character, the platform or
behavior, give the ground the platform behavior.
And we'll give the B the physics engine 2.0
behavior and then for giggles will give the ground
the physics behavior as well.
For the next portion, Max is going to take over
and explain how variables work in G develop.
So variables are used whenever you want to store
some information about your game. For example,
maybe the players health or the player score.
And she developed a variable can live in one of
three places. It can live in the scene, which
is useful for things like a level score that
is explicitly tied to a particular scene. It can
live on the object which is useful for things like
enemy health that are tied to particular objects,
in this case enemies, or it can live globally,
which is useful for things like say a player
selected username that needs to be accessed
from everywhere within your project. Let's
start by taking a look at scene variables.
As you can see, we have here a basic platformer.
However, when we go to pick up a coin,
the score does not increase. We can fix this using
variables. Start by going to the scene properties
and then clicking on the
Edit scene variables button.
Here you can view all of your seen variables and
also add new ones. We'll start by adding a new
score variable and setting its initial value to
zero. Then when the player collides with a coin,
we'll add a new change a scene variable action
which adds to the variable score the value one.
Then we add a new action without a condition
which modifies the scene text object,
we'll use the variable string function which
allows us to access a scene variable from
anywhere and then specify the score variable.
And then finally put the text score in front
using the concatenation or plus operator
to join the text with the variable.
Sure enough, our score counter
is now working as intended.
Next, let's take a look at object variables.
Right now our slime enemy does not move and
what we'd like is for it to move back
and forth between these two markers.
We can start by opening the drop down menu on
the slime object and selecting the Edit object
variables option. This will give us a list of all
of our object variables on this particular object,
we can start by adding a new direction variable
with an initial value of left. Then in our event
sheet, we can add to the slime a text of an object
variable action, which sets the direction to left.
We call this one the slime is in
collision with the left marker.
And then we can do the same
thing for the right as well.
We can then use the text of an object variable
condition to test the direction variable.
When it's left, we'll incorporate our game
logic for moving the slider to the left.
In this case, adding a force and setting
the flip state. And then we can do the
same for the right direction as well. And
now our slime is no longer stationary.
Note that while we've written all of the events
ourselves for this example, to demonstrate
variables, there's plenty of great behaviors
out there to do this for you. We should have a
video on behavior soon if that is foreign to you.
Finally, let's take a look at global variables.
Let's say that our platformer has multiple levels.
If we look at the score as we transition between
these levels, you'll see that it resets.
While this may be what we want, we also
might want more of a global score that stays
the same when we transition between two levels.
We can start by going to the project manager
where we will find the global variables button
then we can add these For variable
much like we did earlier for the scene
now all we have to do is change our scene
variable action to the corresponding global one
and then replace our variable string function
with the global variable string function.
And now, sure enough, our score will carry
on through seeing transition. Very nice.
Now that we've gotten through variables,
I can show you the expression builder.
So to begin with, I'll show you
where the Expression Builder is,
we go to the event sheet and pick an action,
we picked the be enemy and select Rotate.
And trust me, the engine can do a lot more
things than just rotate an object. But it
just seems like the thing that I picked the most.
If I put a one in here, the be enemy will rotate
at an angular speed of one. But if I go to
the expression builder here on the right,
you'll see there's a big list of things
I can search from. These can range from
the size and width of an object to the distance
between two objects, which I'm going to use now.
You'll see that I've multiplied it by
one. And that's just to show you that this
basically works the same way as an algebra
equation, when you're sticking to numbers.
So you can add, subtract, multiply, divide,
use brackets, the whole nine yards. And then
if we go back to the main scene, and give the
player object, the draggable object behavior,
and we press preview, we can then drag the
player closer to the B. And as we do that,
you can see it's slowing down. And that's because
the distance between the B and the player object
is getting smaller. So it's rotating at a slower
speed. But if we move the player away from the B,
it speeds back up again, because it's getting
further away. So the number is bigger.
Now let's get rid of that. And I'll show you
an actual game related example. So I made these
objects earlier, we have a hard object, that's a
sprite, and they hurt object that's a tile Sprite.
So if we put the tile sprite into the
scene, within the camera's default border,
and then put it on the UI layer that I made
earlier, then we can build this first event where
when I release the left mouse button, one time,
we'll create the heart sprite object at the x&y
position of the mouse, then we'll make a second
event with the condition if player is in collision
with heart, and then we'll make the action to
modify the object variable of the player. If we
click on this tool button to the right will
be shown this objects object variable list.
And since it didn't have any, I'm going to click
Add and give it an object variable of health,
and then two as the number. So now when
I click here, it'll show me my options.
And I'll select Add, because what I'm
trying to do is add to the players health,
and one. And then I'm going to create
an action that shows that the player's
health has changed. So if I select the heart
UI object, and select the width of the object,
I'll select it to set to and then click on the
Expression Builder tool, search for object and
select objects variable. Select the player as the
object. And you can see I can click here again,
to display this objects variables. I'm going to
select Health. And because I know the size of the
heart that I made earlier, it's 64 pixels by 64
pixels, I'm going to multiply this width by 64.
This is only going to work because it's a tiled
Sprite, if I pick the regular heart object, which
is a sprite, it would just get all squished up.
Now let's move this into its own event. So it's
checking this every frame. And then as a final
action, we're going to add, delete the heart.
And just to show you that the player doesn't have
to be the thing that gets the platformer controls,
you can literally put these behaviors on any
object, I'm going to put it on the heart. So
what's happening here is that each frame we're
changing the heart UIs size to match the player's
health. And every frame that the left mouse button
is released will create one hurt object at the
mouse position. And every frame that the player
is in collision with a heart, it will add one
to the object variable health of the player
object, and then it will delete that hurt.
So now if we press preview, you'll see the
health UI is up at the top showing two hurts
because it's expanded to two times 64 Because
the players object variable health starts at two.
And now if I release the left mouse button,
it creates a heart at the x&y coordinates
of the mouse. And it does this every time I
click. If I drop one directly on the player,
you'll see that it's added one to the object
variable health because it's being displayed
up top and it will keep adding health
as long as they keep giving it hurts
In the next portion, Max is
going to go over extensions.
You'll see here I've made a fairly simple dungeon
crawler with one enemy and one piece of treasure
to find. As it stands, though, our game leaves
a lot to be desired. For example, maybe we want
to be able to hold down our mouse and shoot at
a fixed cooldown rather than having to click a
button each time. Maybe we want a smart enemy
that can Pathfinder around walls to get to us,
rather than just running into them. And maybe we'd
like the one to point at the cursor. For a more
interactive gameplay experience. We could try to
implement this functionality ourselves, or we can
use functions and behaviors known more broadly as
extensions. Extensions allow us as game creators
to spend less time reinventing the wheel and more
time actually making our game. As an added bonus,
you'll find that using extensions leads to a
much cleaner event sheet, which will help a
lot as your project grows. So let's take a look at
how to use them. We can get started with behaviors
by opening the drop down menu for an object
and selecting the Edit behaviors menu option.
You can then add a behavior with the added
behavior button. And then you'll be presented
with a list of built in behaviors native to do
develop. There's also a plethora of community
made behaviors available through the search new
behaviors option. For this project, we'll select
the fire bullets behavior and install it. And
then we'll see it in our list of new behaviors,
we can then add it to our object by clicking on
it. And then we'll find the behavior properties
here. These give us some more control over how the
behavior will act. So in this case, we can set the
cooldown when we fire a bullet. Now when
we select our objects in the event sheet,
we'll find that it's been basically
supercharged with new abilities. In this case,
our one now has a fire a bolt action, which
we can use to fire bullets towards the mouse.
Now, another problem with our game is that, well,
our AI is a little bit more a than I, we can fix
this by implementing pathfinding, which is just
another behavior in our list, but with a behemoth
of a behavior property list. We'll go over how
to actually implement this in a future video.
Finally, in addition to behaviors, there
are also functions, which can be accessed
from the Project Properties panel, followed by
opening the function slash behaviors menu. This
is where you can find community made functions as
well as behaviors. As for using functions. Well,
there are a lot like behaviors, but
they're not tied to specific objects.
They can do things like for example, align stuff
in your scene, or in the case of this project,
rotate a wand about a character and pointed at
the cursor. looks much better now. But you think.
Now that we've gone through everything
that I consider to be the basics,
we're going to build a game. More specifically,
we're going to recreate asteroids.
I won't be showing you how I'm creating these
events, just the ones that I'm using, but I
will be showing you what I'm doing. So to begin
with, I'm going to be using this space shooter
Redux pack. And I'm going to jump right into
a blank game project. I'll create a new scene,
and I'll create a sprite object named Player. For
this example, I'm going to take advantage of the
physics behavior that comes with G developed
by default. And I'm going to start by leaving
everything alone except for changing the gravity
to zero, so that the object doesn't just fall
out of the sky. So now we'll move over to the
event sheet, and start with a player movement
with the condition if the W key is pressed, and
then the action, apply a physics force towards
the angle the player is facing. And then I'm going
to move the origin of the sprite into the center,
so that we can use that origin point as
the point where forces will be applied.
And then we'll copy our condition for our first
event, and then paste those for the A and D key
presses. And then we'll apply a torque to the
player object based on which key is being pressed.
Take note, this is not just the rotate an object
action. This is apply a torque. It's specific to
the physics behavior. And I'm using this because I
want to make sure that all of the forces are being
applied using the same kind of rules. And now
I have a character that spins out of control.
The problem here is that the sprite isn't the
wrong orientation. So I'm going to open up Pisco,
change its orientation, and then save it. With
that part fixed, I'm going to move on to firing
bullets, using the conditions when the spacebar
is released, and once. And as you can see,
I've created the bullet object already. And since
the bullet is a really bright color, I'm going to
change the background of the scene to black, so
it stands out better. And now for the bullet, we
put the action create object and add a force and
rotate object. But moving the Rotate action above
the apply a force action, because we want to make
sure that it's rotated before it starts moving.
And the bullets orientation is off just like
the players was. So I could go into pistol and
change the orientation of the bullet just like I
did with the player. Or I can add 90 degrees to
the rotation and changes so that the players angle
is the thing that tells it which direction to go.
And after we tweaked the origin of the
bullet, just like we did the player,
it works just fine. Though I do have to change
the Z order, so that the bullet spawns below
the player and not on top. And that's the player
basically done. Next, we'll make another event
for the beginning of scene, where we're going to
change the center of the camera to the zero point
and change the zoom to 0.5. Changing the camera
to the 0.2 so that we could easily do screen wrap.
And zooming the camera out was just so that we
would have a better scale for an asteroid game.
Now let's add some asteroids will add in some
animations and give them the physics 2.0 behavior
plays a couple of scene. And we'll do that
again with medium and small asteroids. And
now because everything has the physics behavior,
I can start knocking things around like marbles.
And just like an asteroids, we're going to make
it so that when you shoot an asteroid, it blows up
into smaller parts. So we'll create a for each
instance event where the object being picked
is the big asteroid, use the condition. If bullet
is in collision with asteroid, then we will create
two medium asteroids, give them a random rotation,
and then apply a force in whichever direction
they're facing. And then we delete the original
asteroid and the bullet. And then we do that two
more times. With the only real difference being
that the small asteroid doesn't spawn anything,
it just gets deleted, we're getting
pretty close to this being asteroids,
we're just missing a couple of things. The
most noticeable one is the screen wrap.
So we're going to create a for each instance
event. And for the object pick this time,
it'll actually be the group everything.
Because I put everything in one group,
this games resolution is 800 by 600. And
because we moved our camera to center on zero,
then we can use this condition. If an object in
the group, everything goes beyond 800 in the x
direction, or goes behind negative 800 in the
x direction, then it will have its exposition
times find negative one, which will flip it to the
other side. And then we just do the same thing for
the y direction. And now we're almost there. The
last thing that's needed for this to be a game
is a failed state. So we're going to go
to the project manager and look for the
extension health. We'll add that to the project.
And now we'll go to the player and select Health,
giving a three as its total, and a five
second cooldown until it can be damaged again.
Then we'll create a tiled sprite and
call it lives. Place it in screen into
the default border of the camera, putting
it onto the UI layer that I made earlier.
And then we use the physics condition
if the player collides with everything.
Note that this will ignore the bullet because
the bullet doesn't have the physics behavior. And
then we'll add the action damage player from the
health extension and then add an action to change
the width of the tile Sprite. And then we'll copy
that action and put it at the beginning of scene
so that it modifies the width of the sprites
at the beginning of the scene as well.
And the one last thing we need
now is for the players to die.
This specific condition comes from the health
extension, and then we'll delete the player.
But on top of that, I'm going to create a text
object called game over and put that on screen
and have it hide during the beginning of the
scene and show up again when the player dies.
And that's how long it takes to recreate asteroids
in G develop. The only real problem being that the
game doesn't have any sound. And it isn't very
much fun to play. It's technically a game, but
it's missing all of its life. We need to add sound
effects and screen shake and particle effects and
all that stuff. So let's get started. For now,
when the player dies, they just get deleted.
So instead we're going to create a particle
effect. To replace that. We're going to make
sure that the ship has a minimum rotation
and that there's only one particle in tank
and we'll make sure to rotate the particles
so it starts with a player stopped.
And now we have a ship that
kind of falls into space.
And we'll use the second particle using
some points to give it a little more flair.
And we could definitely make our game
over text look a little more impressive.
So we're going to give it a custom font, this
being the font that I use for everything developer
related. And then if I give it the glitch effect
from the effects menu, it will look like this,
which is certainly an improvement. Next, we're
going to create some debris for the asteroids
for when they explode. And just like the ship,
we'll be using the texture of the asteroids to
make the effect. And doing this just makes it
more satisfying to look at when the asteroids
explode. A big problem with this game so far is
the lack of player feedback. Specifically when
you get hit, so we're going to go to behaviors,
and add the flash or blink behavior to the project
will slot that action into the event where
the player gets hurt. And now you can see
that the player flashes when they get hit. Another
aspect of player feedback would be sound effects,
something that this game really needs. So we're
going to open up GFX there, randomize the sound
effect until we get something that we like. And
then title it laser fire and save it. You may
want to put it in a variable for the sound here,
but I'm just going to put it in 150. For now,
for sounds that happen once in a while, you can
just put one here, but for sounds are going to
happen over and over again, you want to have
a randomized pitch. Otherwise, you're going
to drive your players insane. So to randomize
something, all we have to do is type in random,
and it will show us our options. And I'm going
to pick random float in range, and put in 0.9
and 1.1. This means that every time the sound
effect is played, it will pick a number between
0.9 and 1.1. To play at, I'll slide that
action over to where the laser effect is
actually happening. But we're going to do this for
everything in the game, which includes a collision
effect when the player runs into an asteroid and
an explosion sound when the asteroids explode.
And now we need just one more thing as far as
effects go. And that's the camera shake. So we're
going to add that to the project, and then go to
the getting hurt event and adding it as an action.
And there we go. And now for a little more polish,
we gave all the asteroids a bunch of animations.
So we're going to go to the beginning
of scene event and use the action
change the number of the animation. And
this time, we're going to use random three,
because the big asteroid has four
animations, and the zero counts as a number.
And now if we start the scene, you'll see
that they've all picked a different image.
And now for the somewhat tedious part of tweaking
things, making sure that your collision masks make
sense with the objects, and then play testing
it. And then making sure that your speeds and
densities are all the way you want them. And then
you play test it again, and again. And again.
And again. And again. And again. And again. And
again. And again. And this is a bit subjective,
but you keep play testing and tweaking
it until the game feels good to play.
Now that we've created a game, we should
do a few things before we export it.
So we're going to go to the Properties manager,
go to game settings and open up properties. We're
going to give the game the proper name, give
it its version number, change its package name,
make sure that you're listed
as one of or the only author.
Make sure that you've chosen the right option
for how the game should expand in a screen.
And of course, for mobile games, you want to make
sure that you've chosen your device's orientation.
And finally, make sure that you've put in
a publisher name. One more thing to do too,
is to give your game icons. All you have to
do is click up here, give it a square image,
and it will turn that image into an
appropriate size for all the devices.
Once that's all done, we can export our
game, we go up to file, click on Export.
And right now we're given two options, share
with friends, which will give you a link that
you can share with your friends or people that
you want to play test the game or publisher game.
You can build it manually if you know how.
But I'm just going to click on the button
that gets the engine to build it for
you. We're showing four different tabs,
starting with the web build, which will create a
HTML file that can be played in browser. Next is
the mobile export, where you can release
an APK to be used on devices generally,
or an Android app bundle, which is the kind
of bundle that you need to submit a game to
Google Play. The next type is for exporting a
game to Windows, Linux or Mac iOS. And finally
There's instant games, which are posted to
Facebook with a Facebook developer account.
Now, g develop is free, entirely free to use and
export from. But there are restrictions for these
automated builds. Because it cost you develop
money to host the servers that they're built on.
So with G develop, you get two free builds per
day from mobile or desktop. If you pay for a
subscription to a G develop account, you get more
exports per day. But publishing a HTML build is
unlimited. So excuse me for breaking the illusion
for one second. Oh, no, I'm on a regular old PC.
Okay, so we create a new folder called game, or
whatever your game is called. Go back into the
engine, click choose folder, find that folder and
select it. And then just press export. So now all
of the game's files are in this folder and ready
to go. All you have to do is compress it to a zip
folder. And that zip folder is your game. But let
me quickly show you how to do it for a PC build.
So we go to exports publisher store, make sure
that Windows auto installer file is selected,
and then just click package. And then you just
wait. You'll get this notification here down
at the bottom. And if you click that button,
you'll get a periodic email that gives you some
stats about your game. And if you just click
that Windows button there, it will download
to your download folder. And then you'll have
your game on your computer. I hope this video
was able to help anybody out there who wanted
to try out g develop and making their own games,
but just didn't know where to start. Thank you
for watching, and best of luck with your games.